pendant tout le monde m'appelle feuilles
ou une petite question quand vous étiez
mon âge
aimez-vous l'école savez vous que selon
les statistiques du gouvernement canada
38 points sept de nos jeunes diplômés
juge
la plupart de ce qu'ils ont appris au
secondaire inutile en france c'est
encore pire 71 % disent les français
selon l'ars ministre de l'éducation
nationale dit s'ennuie au collège
l'ennui scolaire est un enjeu majeur ses
conséquences comme le taux de décrochage
est élevé et un manque de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée sont épouvantables
surtout aujourd'hui nos prédécesseurs
quitte la scène et c'est nous
l'arriération z qui doivent supporter
seules le fardeau lourd d'améliorer ces
situations problématiques
et voici comment puisque les
psychologues et les pitas gueule
remarque que le plus grand facteur
maintien de l'année scolaire et que nos
élèves manque de passion en grèce qui
étudient voici ma solution contre cet
enjeu nos enseignants doivent être eux
mêmes qualifie et surtout passionné gras
ce sont deux conditions essentielles
pour que nos élèves développent de
passion avant tout pour que nos
enseignants et veille la passion des
élèves
il faut d'abord que les élèves
comprennent bien ce qu'ils étudient et
pour que les élèves à une image juste et
complète de la matière qui étudie les
enseignants craie l'ifi qui ont des
bonnes méthodes d'enseignement sont
indispensables le meilleur exemple pour
prouver l'importance d'avoir une
éducation de qualité et sans doute une
question de finances ce pays de 5.3
millions d'habitants est le premier de
classe en europe dans son éducation au
primaire et au secondaire leur système
d'éducation et d'enseignement sert
d'exemple
pour tous les pays du monde et que
pouvons-nous apprendre eux d'abord tous
les enseignants ont passé par les
sélections rigoureuse et sévère
prenons les chefs de 2013 sur plus de
douze mille candidats qui sont inscrits
pensionnat langue chinoise seulement 886
sont acceptés seulement 7%
ensuite séquence de choisy vont recevoir
une longue période de formation
professionnelle pour leur enseigner les
meilleures méthodes d'enseignement
existantes
conséquemment leurs enseignants sont
d'élite parmi 18 et il va sans dire que
leur qualité d'enseignement est
excellente avec un enseignement de cette
qualité fin langue maintient un record
dans le plus beau de couture de
décrochage au monde avec cet exemple il
est déjà très évident qu'il existe une
forte corrélation positive entre la
qualité d'enseignement et la réussite
scolaire bien sûr ce n'est pas tout sur
la fondation solide d'un enseignement de
qualité assuré il faut que nous y 14
soit passionné comme pour les livres
l'enseignant et son modèle surtout au
secondaire dans cette période de
formation des intérêts et de découverte
de passion l'impact de passion des
enseignants est pas ignorer en effet une
découverte intéressante de niro science
nous aidera à mieux comprendre comment
nos infos l'influencent des patients des
enseignants est grande
c'est la découverte des neurones miroirs
les neurones miroirs sont 1 100 de myron
qui a pour fonction de sentir les
émotions des autres de ton entourage et
repose sur ces mêmes émotions dans votre
propre cerveau un simple exemple avant
l'examen décisif et disent ils
entouré de vos camarades anxieux
stressés
même si vous n'étiez pas vous allez
aussi avant un peu par entouré de ses
jeunes espoirs
ce qui est tout à fait normal
entouré de ces personnes vos neurones
miroirs ont ressenti leur part et ont
produit cette anxiété dans votre propre
tête et si on applique cette théorie en
éducation en enseignements il est facile
d'arriver à la conclusion que souvent
juste en manifestant leur propre désir
passion et curiosité même juste en
souriant en classe non plus la gorgue
peuvent grandement influencé nos jeunes
ils peuvent capter leur attention
susciter la curiosité et mind
transmettre leur passion aux élèves
quand insensiblement et transmet un
message tellement important et ceci
comme moi je suis si heureux si content
quand je vous apprends tout ça ce que je
vous en chine est nécessairement
intéressant attirant passionnant même
incontournable
autrement si nos enseignants
transmettent ainsi le plaisir
d'apprendre et une fois nouvelle et
possède le président plaisir d'apprendre
waouh ils auront la motivation et c'est
la motivation qui veut les pousser plus
loin études c'est la motivation qui va
donner le courage de surmonter toutes
les épreuves en psychologie
on appelle ces centres d'apprentissage
comme apprentissage motivée par des
intérêts et la passion sert de facteurs
déclencheurs qui a permis à nos élèves
de vaincre la paresse d'amorcer un
cheminement
il est finalement arrivé à la réussite
tout une passion sans exception de
charles darwin à al bayda aristote aka
liong ces grands scientifiques quand les
étés jeunes y ont tous été inspiré
orienter et guider par des enseignants
des amis passionnés
certes former les enseignants qualifiés
passionnés exige beaucoup de ressources
et de la persévérance de plusieurs
décennies mais pensons plutôt demain
n'est-il pas vrai que l'éducation ne
doit jamais considéré comme une dépense
mais le plus profitable investissement
pour l'avenir
de plus je me rappelle que l'un de mes
flows a préféré lancer une fois 2e
un voyage de mille stade a débuté par un
pont et ce premier projet sif s'est
trouvé la bonne orientation
c'est pourquoi on est ici maintenant une
fois on trouve vers où on va aller ce
qui nous reste est de persévérer et de
tels travailler sans cesse
année après année génération général
après génération pas après pau
peu importe comment la route à parcourir
est longue
un jour on voit certainement y arriver
et ça j'en suis certain merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]